the supreme court has wrapped up its
term with two more major decisions on
the environment and immigration and
justice gatanji brown jackson is now on
the bench as the first black woman to
serve on the nation's highest court jan
crawford is at the supreme court this
morning where the justices are already
looking forward to this fall jan great
to see you
yeah i mean this was one of the most
momentous terms in the supreme court's
history you had those rulings on
abortion gun climate change a school
prayer and now we have a new justice
justice kataji brown jackson she is
going to be stepping onto a divided
court that's going to be taking up more
contentious cases next fall
i catanji brown jackson do solemnly
swear in a private ceremony with the
justices and her family katanji brown
jackson made history the 116th associate
justice and first black female on the
nation's highest court
it was a moment of hope and collegiality
to end an historic and divisive term up
to the very end
on thursday the court limited the epa's
authority to regulate greenhouse gases
from power plants saying it exceeded its
power under the 1970 clean air act which
was written before climate change was an
issue the ruling puts the ball in
congress's court to update the
52-year-old law
it's a setback for the biden
administration's efforts to tackle
climate change but top officials vowed
to fight on this is about protecting
public health this is about advancing
our interests of our families and our
workers we're going to keep moving
forward even though the supreme court
would like to look backwards and hold us
back in a separate opinion the high
court thursday sided with the biden
administration allowing it to end the
trump-era policy of requiring asylum
seekers at the southern border to remain
in mexico while their claims were
decided
the court's latest term saw a
blockbuster ruling overturning roe
versus wade and letting states set their
own abortion policies
a decision that sparked protest across
the country as politicians and state
courts scrambled to respond the decision
along with other rulings this term on
school prayer guns and climate change
shows a court that is firmly turned to
the right with six conservatives and
three liberals in replacing liberal
justice stephen breyer jackson will not
change the balance of the court
but there is a saying that a new justice
makes a new court so she is certain to
have an impact and we'll see that begin
in the fall when the court takes up
other cases including affirmative action
voting rights gay rights and election
procedures gail
i watched the swearing-in ceremony it
was really a wonderful thing to see
thank you very much jan